je suis partagé entre déception et
valeo tristesse parce que j'ai pris la
décision d'arrêter de mettre fin à ma
saison
parce que c'est pas la première
agression et sam est la première du rang
après la première version j'ai été
égoïste
j'ai pensé à ma famille j'ai pas pensé à
ma famille et mon entourage j'ai voulu
continuer l'arbitrage ma passion tandis
que maintenant ça touche ça touche à mon
entourage à ma famille mes proches ont
essuyé aux invectives et partout où ils
vont et j'ai plus envie de théorie j'ai
envie de penser à mon entourage et à
moi-même aussi parce que moi même je
suis un petit peu touché touché par sa
est touché par le fait que ma mon
évolution dans l'arbitrage soit soit
atteinte
parce que je ne faut pas oublier que
j'ai 25 ans et que j'estime avoir bien
pour l'instant un parcours
atypique youtube a couru ici de mon
point de vue j'ai c'est de continuer à
gravir des échelons et a porté haut les
couleurs de l'arbitrage martiniquais et
voilà je me retrouve bloqué sur entre
réflexion est en vie et voilà je pense
que je vais prendre la meilleure
décision pour moi et mon entourage
non ce n'est pas normal que ça arrive
dans le sport tout court ou pas dans le
football et seulement mais dans tout
l'est dans tous les sports il faudrait
qu'on soit à même de respecter
l'arbitrage de comprendre que dans tous
les sports et que ceci est un jeu il
faudrait aussi comprendre que le jeu
s'arrête au coup de sifflet final il
faut il faut prendre du recul sur
beaucoup de situations et
respecter aussi l'avis des arbitres
parce que l'orbité un être humain c'est
pas un robot il a aussi des proches il a
aussi une femme il a aussi un coeur et
c'est simplement ça que je vais moi
j'aimerais qu'à l'avenir les gens
puissent comprendre oui là la commission
la commission adjaho si tu oublieras
peau et la plata sera dépouille a été
déposée et il faudra que kylie est déçu
de toute façon parce que la ligue va se
saisir de tout le dossier et non je vais
pas laisser s'apprécier je vais pas
laisser cette cette agression passé yat
unification je pense qu'il ya une
certaine forme de fanatisme les
certaines personnes se rendent comptent
parfois que la réaction humaine va un
peu trop loin il ya d'autres qu'ils ne
sont par contre ils se rendent compte
trop temps et je pense que si dans tous
et pas seulement dans le sport il
faudrait qu'on puisse nous dire in aux
propos modérés nos paroles parce que je
ne serais ce que quand on conduit le
sauva sur la route ne serait-ce que
partout la violence est partout et je
pense qu'il faudrait éradiquer tous et
tous ces comportements là pour qu'on
puisse être un petit peu plus dans un
climat serein en martinique vous de vous
arrêter
alors je vous trouve toujours dire que
ma saison est terminée parce qu'on sait
pas de quoi est fait demain mais je
pense que j'ai oui j'ai pris ma décision
définitive tout simplement parce que
j'ai pensé je ne pense pas qu'à moi
cette fois ci donc je pense qu'il va
falloir faire sans moi et c'est
attention aux contours ne sont pas
contents mais je pense que la décision
m'appartient
tout simplement